[Música]
em 2011 o joão eo pai vieram ao meu
laboratório na faculdade de ciências
o joão tinha nove anos os olhos grande
mas um olhar muito prazer a ela sempre
me mandar o pai e quando não estava num
sítio confortava fazia muitas vezes como
toda criança gostava de brincar
gostava de brincar especialmente josé
computador mas vamos brincava sempre
sozinho
o joão tem autismo seu melhor e não
conseguia comunicar se com sua família
quando o pai joão descobriu que a
universia estavam saindo instigar novas
técnicas para interagir com crianças com
autismo vieram e nessa linha julho de
jogaram na sua já o experimental que
permite alinhar a e fazer mímica de
expressões emoções em personagens 3d
avatar com o objetivo de tentar ajudar o
joão a melhorar a sua forma de
comunicação ea melhorar o reconhecimento
das emoções
então eu preparei uma sala com sofás
para o jogo o país cresça confortável
eles ficaram lá por horas a jogada
estava fora e só conseguiu observar como
o pai pegava na mão do filho que teve em
mim mesmo para que eu consiga desenhar
todo o esforço eo carinho que o pai
cunha para conseguir tentar comunicar se
com a filha passado muitas horas
acontece uma coisa mágica
o jogo começou a sorrir
isso eu aprendi imenso
eu pensei o que é importante neste
momento é a confiança ea empatia e o
carinho que o pai estava fora para ela
realmente conseguir comunicar
e agora como nós conseguimos transmitir
estes sentimentos no mundo digital
nós não conseguimos pegar numa
personagem em 3d
iser tem empatia o simpático isto
simplesmente não vai funcionar
mas o que foi mais incrível foi o que
aconteceu a seguir o pai do joão
mesmo eu posso lançar agora este avatar
para comunicar melhor com o meu filho e
isso foi o que realmente me fez pensar
quando nós não temos
não sou eu digital quando nós não
estávamos presenta à forma que todos
aqui nesta sala e eu inclusive
comunicavam pelo telefone e por email e
mandando mensagens
hoje de manhã o meu filho estava ali mas
não uma mensagem de boa sorte e eu
responder um coração um beijo tinha um
bater palmas
eu estava aqui mas agora eu acredito que
se eu digo é obrigado e olho para ela é
muito mais importante a que alencar e
depois provavelmente tão envergonhado
então o que realmente é será que nós
conseguimos como joão criar uma nova
maneira nem ter actuado com o mundo
digital a partir de uma personagem
virtual será que nós conseguimos criar
uma personagem virtual que consiga
transmitir aos mesmos sentimentos
será que nós conseguimos criar uma
personagem virtual que uma extensão da
empatia humana
então em 2003 eu comecei a estudar
investigar na área de computação gráfica
com um objetivo muito claro
eu queria conseguir automatizar o
processo de criação de personagens 3 né
para poder ser usado em jogos ea filme
procura fazer isto sem é necessário
artistas engenheiros muitas semanas
dezenas de milhares de euros
é necessário compreender a complexidade
das nossas caras da nossa fisionomia
todos temos com a coroa tom de cor
diferente na tabela e mesmo quando há
expressões muitos movimentos
temos que conseguir capturar cada
detalhe da nossa cara pra conseguir
depois de reproduzir fielmente a
morfologia e os comportamentos para que
então o nosso personagem 3 né seja
realmente queriam eu tentei automatizar
tudo isto faria absolutamente só
consegui na altura solucionar um
problema pequena mas não desisti
demorei muito tempo para encontrar uma
solução mas o mais importante foi a
solução foi o ponto que eu descobri lei
aumenta para que esta tecnologia poderia
ser utilizada como no caso joão eo pai
então eu acredito que nós conseguimos
realmente agora forma em como nos inter
atuamos no mundo digital criando uma
nova maneira de melhor qualidade e para
isso tenho a oportunidade única de
conseguir trabalhar num projecto europeu
com meus liderada por meus leitores era
na área realidade virtual
agora se nós pensamos na realidade
virtual
o que nós temos que conseguir fazer era
e convencer o nosso cérebro que aquilo
que estamos a ver é real para depois
podermos pôr no centro da experiência e
sentir que estamos a viver uma
experiência diferente solucionado dois
caças
em um delas para pessoas com
incapacidade física ficaria com uma
perna amputada um braço amputado
o objetivo neste caso era fazer sentir
as pessoas que conseguiram voltar a
andar conseguiam voltar a mexer sá
por isso toda essa experiência foi que
as pessoas conseguia mesmo naquelas o
nosso corpo e que tenha uma parte
amputada conseguir controlar a
personagem em 3d porque os próprios
sentia que era ela se chama assembléia
alimenta o outro caso de violência
você quiser vai neste caso a 1
o agressor sem primeiro a idéia é
perceber que estamos a tentar agredir
pessoas que elas realmente querem então
é será que nós conseguimos ajudar essas
pessoas a reabilitar sá
o resultado das experiências conseguiu
que nós conseguimos aumentar a empatia
nessas prender essas pessoas só o fato
de por a pessoa o agressor no corpo da
vítima e ver se é o próprio ser agredida
como este caso
a lista é enorme o efeito de 4 potente
pode ser nós temos o nosso erro digital
no entorno 3 v
mas agora eu quero partilhar convosco o
meu sonho eu espero que no fim seja
também um bocadinho vossa assim juntos
podemos construir o meu sonho é poder
utilizar esta tecnologia para poder
criar uma plataforma de aprendizagem
criança a criança como qualquer criança
em qualquer parte do mundo consiga terá
a oportunidade de aprender porque então
juntas vão conseguir criar mais
conhecimento e juntas conseguiram
encontrar o desafio no sul localidades
espanholas em qualquer parte do mundo
como uma nova solução
então a minha missão e ajudar a minha
tia ela da argentina e dedicou a vida
inteira a construir escolas nos sítios
mais remotos que vocês possam imaginar
na patagônia no norte da argentina na
selva onde as crianças às vezes fazem
desenhos escrevem cartas e demoram
semanas e mexer em ter uma resposta
agora será que nós conseguimos com esta
plataforma acelerar o processo e
incluí-las neste mundo tecnológico que
nós temos hoje em dia nós conseguimos
uma coisa ainda mais importante a que
escalar a educação nós conseguimos
através do nosso eu digital que uma das
tantas coisas que podem fazer é falar a
ter comportamento
falando em 30 línguas sim nós
conseguimos com uma fotografia e em
segundo
criar o nosso é o digital estará
disponível para estas crianças como
elemento de comunicação
então pensei agora essas crianças que
está instalada geograficamente
tecnológicamente socialmente em muitas
partes do mundo as pessoas pensam que é
o oposto da educação é ignorância mas no
fundo o oposto à educação e muitas
portas
eu e salvamento
eu acredito firmemente é que em cinco
anos
não vamos conseguir ter no seu digital
em todos os telemóveis e poder partilhar
lo em grandes sociais nesses temas
educação qualquer aplicação que vocês
querem alimentar e que o nosso dever era
quem dera ter consciência do que a
tecnologia o poder que isto popular
nós temos que poder controlar eu sou eu
digital
não temos que deixar que a inteligência
artificial ou os bots tomem o poder da
nossa identidade
então para fechar o que eu acho
importante consciencializar é que nós
não queremos é virtualizar a humanidade
se não o que queremos é que uma análise
tecnologia
eu
yang
ele é legal
[Aplausos]